any here that had dramas ranging from
evolve launching with a hundred and
thirty dollars worth of day 1 dlc to
destiny dropping dinklage and the
frontman for breaking benjamin raging
against star wars battlefront it was
pretty hard to get this list down to
just five that said here's what blew up
the industry in 2015 last year we saw
some painful Kickstarter failures
including the cancelled Yogscast game
this year we saw even more scrutiny over
the security of the crowdfunding service
this year we felt more than ever that
just because we successfully backed a
project did not mean we get our money's
worth the stomping learned raised 114
thousand bucks two years ago and this
year it was totally abandoned by its
creator who stopped responding to emails
and did not take his artists another
developer Grimm filed for bankruptcy
after they delivered a poorly received
first episode of wolf the Red Hood
Diaries they said they would not be able
to fulfill Kickstarter pledges did not
intend to make another chapter in the
game and said it feels horrible to live
with the feeling we let you down luckily
for them the game has been picked up by
another publisher The Witcher 3 saucy
unicorn build sex scenes caused
something of a stir in 2015 but it was a
Final Fantasy 15 character who caused
the most controversy by being quote too
sexy the series of staple mechanic and
inventor characters Sid had a gender
swap revealed Sid was now Cindy who
sports a fetching yellow cropped jacket
in dire need of a new zip a salmon
push-up bra and denim hotpants that said
she was actually not meant to be an
erotic character according to game
director Hajime Tabata he explained the
car mechanic character is just a really
chirpy outgoing girl and those traits
were paired with her appearance adding
we feel it wouldn't be too problematic
if she shows up on screen while your
parents are in the living room maybe not
your parents to barter
every delayed and buggy game got
something of a free pass this year
thanks to Batman Arkham Knight on PC
which launched so so broken and it's
still broken after multiple delays the
game finally came out in June in what we
can only assume was a duct tape and
super glue state almost instantly
reports flooded in about all sorts of
bugs and crashes Warner Brothers pulled
the pc version off shelves and steam and
in October they began to issue full
refunds to anyone who purchased the game
the studio has been releasing patches
and working on the game for the second
half of this year but many people are
still reporting issues it's all been
quite a big fatness really about of
controversy blew up toward the end of
this year when people were led to
believe that voyeuristic beach
volleyball game Dead or Alive Xtreme 3
would not be coming to the west due to
its sexualized depiction of its female
characters a poorly worded post on
developer kohutek most facebook page
responded to a question asking about the
game's Western release by saying Dead or
Alive Xtreme 3 would not come to the
west the reply appeared to suggest that
the reason for this was as a result of
the Western debate over the depiction of
women in games that statement fueled the
debate over censorship vs. misogyny as
some gamers felt they wouldn't be
granted access to the game due to an
alleged outcry over its questionable
depiction of women kohutek mo later
explained that they want to support
different global audiences and focus on
their fans around the world explaining
the facebook comment wasn't
representative of the company and
finally 2015 was certainly the year of
hadera Kajima vs konami drama we still
don't know exactly what's gone down
between the industry heavyweights but it
sure is getting ugly back in march
inside sources confirmed to gamespot
that the two had fallen out as go Gemma
would leave Konami at the end of the
year Kojima Productions branding was
stripped from everything affiliated with
little gift solid pipe you know the game
they made and Kojima silent Hills
project was cancelled although in New
York Times journal staff to picture of a
leavings there
emoni for kojima in october Kaname
insisted he was simply on vacation a new
revelation came during December's Game
Awards when host Jeff Healey revealed
that karma had been barred from
attending the show by Konami lawyers as
of December 15 Kojima's contract with
Konami ended kajima has now formed an
independent studio and is working with
PlayStation on the first game so that's
you covered off on the games industry
drama of 2015 I do hope you enjoyed it
as much as I did and I will have another
episode for you in January of next year
have great holidays and I will catch you
then
you